Voici ce qu’écrit Michel Onfray
dans sa préface des Essais :
« Montaigne est le plus grand philosophe
de l’Occident judéochrétien, mais, depuis
un siècle ou deux, les philosophes officiels, ceux
de l’institution et de l’université, des académies
et de la subversion officielle, ne le savent pas
— pire : ils ne veulent pas le savoir ; pire que
pire : ils affirment même parfois qu’il
n’est pas philosophe ! »
D’après Michel Onfray, les philosophes
académiques sont jaloux de Montaigne.
Ils ne veulent pas reconnaître qu’il
a été le premier, au XVIe siècle,
à faire leurs découvertes philosophiques.
Et ils peuvent être d’autant plus jaloux que
Montaigne, lui, a eu une vie bien remplie.
Il ne s’est pas contenté de fréquenter
les livres.
Avant Descartes,
il a compris et affirmé que rien ne remplace «
le livre du monde », c’est-à-dire les expériences
concrètes, au contact des gens.
Comparé aux érudits de la Renaissance,
la vie de Montaigne est donc très originale.
Elle est pleine d’anecdotes fascinantes — mais
certaines sont troublantes.
La famille de Montaigne appartient
à la petite noblesse — donc ils vivent dans un
château, au sein de leur domaine en Dordogne.
La coutume, dans ce milieu social, c’est de
mettre les nouveaux-nés en nourrice.
Mais le père de Montaigne s’en fout,
de la coutume aristocratique.
À l’hiver 1533, il confie donc le nourrisson
à de pauvres bûcherons qui vivent dans un
petit village de son domaine.
Cette anecdote révèle que Montaigne est
ce qu’on peut appeler un « métisse social ».
Avant de connaître le confort et les privilèges
de l’aristocratie, il a vécu, dès ses
premières années, avec les plus humbles.
Du coup, sa conscience
sociale est double.
Et c’est l’objectif de son père.
Il veut non seulement habituer son fils
au mode de vie le plus simple, mais surtout
l’attacher émotionnellement au peuple.
Ça va le conditionner à remplir ses devoirs
d’aristocrate envers les plus modestes.
On peut trouver que la décision du père
est rude, surtout pour les toutes premières
années de son enfant.
Et peut-être que ça aurait
pu traumatiser l’enfant.
Mais Montaigne lui-même estimera
que c’était une très bonne idée.
Il sera reconnaissant à son père de
l’avoir libéré des préjugés dès le berceau.
Et il dira même que s’il avait eu des fils,
il aurait fait la même chose.
À 4 ans, Montaigne est de retour au château.
Il se produit un phénomène étonnant au
cours des années suivantes : certains
mots et prénoms latins se mettent à circuler
jusque loin dans les villages voisins.
Or, seuls les érudits et la haute
société parlent le latin à l’époque.
Si des mots latins se diffusent dans les classes
inférieures dans le domaine des Montaigne,
c’est parce que le père force les domestiques du
château à s’adresser en latin à son fils.
Alors bien sûr, les domestiques
ne deviennent pas bilingues.
Ils apprennent simplement les mots,
expressions et phrases dont ils ont
besoin au quotidien dans leurs
interactions avec l’enfant.
Cette anecdote révèle que Montaigne est le
produit d’une expérience éducative.
Son père, qui est très cultivé,
sait l’importance du latin.
Pour faire simple, c’est
la langue de l’élite.
Et comme il a de l’ambition pour son fils, il
veut qu’il maîtrise parfaitement le latin.
Mais il sait aussi que l’apprentissage du
latin est particulièrement pénible.
Ses amis humanistes lui ont expliqué qu’il
est possible d’apprendre naturellement,
sans effort, sans rigueur ni contrainte. Donc
il applique cette idée pour le latin.
Comment est-ce qu’il s’y prend concrètement ?
Il fait venir au château un érudit allemand qui
a une maîtrise parfaite du latin, mais
ne parle pas un mot de français.
Ça lui coûte très cher, mais l’éducation de
son fils est très importante pour lui.
Il adjoint même à l’érudit allemand
deux assistants, eux aussi érudits.
Ces trois hommes ont l’interdiction
totale de parler à Montaigne dans
une autre langue que le latin.
Mais comment est-ce que les autres
personnes du château — la mère, le père
lui-même, et puis les domestiques — comment
doivent-ils parler à l’enfant ?
S’ils lui parlent en français,
son immersion linguistique
en latin ne sera pas totale,
et le père craint que cela ne dégrade
la qualité du latin de son fils.
Il impose donc une autre règle : la famille
et les domestiques doivent d’abord se faire
inculquer par les érudits les bribes de latin
nécessaires pour s’adresser à l’enfant.
Résultat ?
À 6 ans, Montaigne parle parfaitement latin.
Et il a appris cette langue sans manuel,
sans grammaire, sans effort.
Vous pouvez appliquer les mêmes principes
pour apprendre une langue étrangère.
D’après l’« Hypothèse de l’input
» du linguiste Stephen Krashen,
la meilleure manière d’apprendre une langue est
d’être exposé à des messages qu'on comprend.
Donc, au lieu de mémoriser des listes de
vocabulaire et des règles de grammaire,
il vaut mieux lire et écouter plein de
choses dans la langue qu'on veut apprendre,
en s'assurant qu'on comprend le sens général.
En fait, il suffit de refaire avec une
langue étrangère ce qu’on a fait pour
apprendre sa langue maternelle.
L’expérimentation menée par le père de
Montaigne vise à ce que son fils le dépasse
en maîtrise du latin, et plus généralement
qu’il le dépasse intellectuellement.
Après, il y a des choses que
l’éducation ne peut pas changer.
Montaigne est minuscule comme son père.
Étant donné que les plus grands chevaliers du
Moyen Âge mesuraient à peine 1,60 m, Montaigne
est probablement autour d’1,40 m.
À lire ce qu’il en dit dans les Essais, il
n’est pas trop complexé par sa taille.
Mais il déplore tout de même
deux inconvénients.
D’abord, ça attire l’attention.
Et puis, ça amoindrit son autorité.
À 25 ans, célibataire dissipé, Montaigne est
conseiller dans une cour de Périgueux spécialisée
dans les affaires fiscales.
C’est pas super prestigieux.
Donc c’est de justesse qu’il est invité à une
fête des membres du Parlement de Bordeaux.
Il y rencontre un autre magistrat, de 3
ans son aîné, Étienne de La Boétie.
C’est le coup de foudre (amical).
Ainsi naît une des plus célèbres
amitiés de l’histoire occidentale.
Les deux plus grands penseurs français du
XVIe siècle, l’auteur du fameux Discours de
la servitude volontaire et celui des fameux
Essais — La Boétie et Montaigne vivent une
fusion affective et intellectuelle.
Inséparables, ils partagent toutes leurs
émotions et toutes leurs pensées.
Ils se comprennent mutuellement à un niveau
très profond, comme si leurs cœurs et leurs
esprits ne faisaient qu'un.
Si leur amitié est légendaire,
c’est aussi en raison de sa fin tragique
: La Boétie meurt à 32 ans, soit 5 ans
seulement après leur rencontre.
Montaigne en est bouleversé.
Il admire le Discours de la servitude
volontaire au point qu’il pense l’inclure
dans ses Essais. Finalement, il renonce —
il trouve le discours trop scolaire.
Et puis le propos est controversé pour l’époque,
surtout dans le contexte des guerres de religion
qui divisent la France.
Mais la postérité de Montaigne
assurera celle de La Boétie.
Dans les dernières années de sa vie,
Montaigne annote un exemplaire de
la première édition des Essais.
Il se demande pourquoi il aimait tant
La Boétie. Il ne sait pas trop.
Il écrit dans la marge : « Parce que
c’était lui, parce que c’était moi ».
Après, leur relation n’est pas
entièrement spontanée.
Comme ils sont tous les deux fans de la culture
de l’Antiquité, ils suivent le modèle antique
de l’amitié idéale : deux hommes qui s’aident à
grandir intellectuellement et moralement.
Cicéron est un des théoriciens
les plus connus de ce modèle.
Un jour, Montaigne fait inscrire en latin
sur le mur de sa bibliothèque :
« L’an du Christ 1571, à l’âge de trente-huit ans,
la veille des calendes de mars, anniversaire de
sa naissance, Michel de Montaigne, dégoûté depuis
longtemps de l’esclavage de la cour et des charges
publiques, se sentant encore en pleine vigueur,
vint se reposer sur le sein des doctes vierges,
dans le calme et la sécurité ; il y franchira
les jours qui lui restent à vivre. »
Donc à seulement 38 ans, il
arrête la politique.
Il abandonne sa charge de magistrat ; il se retire
sur ses terres, et prévoit de consacrer le reste
de ses jours à l’étude et à la réflexion.
Et cette décision est si sérieuse pour lui qu’il
crée un rappel permanent dans sa bibliothèque
pour s’interdire tout retour dans le monde.
Mais pourquoi cette décision ?
Simplement, parce qu’il le peut.
En effet, la mort de son père 2 ans
plus tôt a fait de lui un rentier.
Un riche rentier.
Montaigne dispose d’une belle fortune qui
le met complètement à l’abri du besoin.
Après, il devient aussi le nouveau chef
de famille, ce qui fait qu’il endosse la
responsabilité de tout le patrimoine.
Il va devoir gérer les mille petites affaires
et transactions journalières du domaine.
Il a aussi les soucis d’un père de famille.
Mais bon, il a quand même beaucoup de temps à
consacrer… À LUI-MÊME.
Pardon pour l’interruption,
mais j’ai une question à vous poser :
Vous croyez VRAIMENT que les gens ont lu tous
les livres dont ils parlent ?
Bien sûr que non — sinon on
ne pourrait pas parler de grand-chose.
Eh oui, il y a vingt-quatre heures dans une
journée, et il faut travailler, manger, dormir,
et sortir le chien.
Donc le secret de la culture générale,
ce n’est PAS de lire des livres.
C’est quoi alors ?
Eh bien en fait,
il n’y a pas qu’un seul secret, il y en a CINQ.
Les étudiants et les personnes les plus cultivés,
les profs, et les intellectuels
CONNAISSENT ces cinq secrets,
mais ils se gardent bien d’en parler…
Les gens qui les découvrent réussissent
à développer RAPIDEMENT et FACILEMENT
leur culture générale, parce que leur
rapport au savoir A CHANGÉ.
Et une fois qu’ils APPLIQUENT
les cinq secrets, ils comprennent toutes
les références des personnes cultivées ;
ils savent s’exprimer avec profondeur
sur n’importe quel sujet ;
ils brillent par leur culture dans les
conversations et dans les débats ;
et ils ont le recul nécessaire pour
faire preuve d’esprit critique.
Ça vous intéresse ?
Eh bien je vous révèle les cinq secrets,
et je vous explique comment
les appliquer DÈS AUJOURD’HUI
pour vous cultiver DIX FOIS PLUS
RAPIDEMENT SANS VOUS PRENDRE LA TÊTE.
Pour recevoir les cinq secrets, inscrivez-vous
simplement soit en cliquant sur le lien qui
apparaît maintenant en haut à droite de la
vidéo, soit en cliquant sur celui qui est
dans la description de la vidéo.
C’est l’histoire de 10 secondes,
donc faites-le maintenant,
et vous pourrez découvrir le premier secret,
qui vous attendra bien au chaud dans votre
boîte mail après avoir regardé cette vidéo.
Voilà voilà, je vous ai dit
ce que je voulais vous dire.
Bonne vidéo !
La customisation de la bibliothèque
de Montaigne ne se résume pas au rappel de sa
décision qu’il fait inscrire sur le mur.
Il fait également peindre des
maximes latines sur les poutres.
Son idée, c’est que quand il lèvera les yeux,
il apercevra des formules de sagesse apaisantes.
C’est un peu de l’autoconditionnement.
Parmi la cinquantaine de formules, il y en a une
seule en français : « Que sais-je ? ».
C’est la devise de Montaigne,
emblématique de son approche sceptique.